we mentioned this several times but the
SW in the resource folder name stands
for smallest width to drive home that
point let's walk through a hypothetical
situation say you have an app directory
structure like this we have some layouts
defined in the base layout folder and we
override some of those in the layout SW
600 DP folder we also override one of
these in the layout SW 720p folder let's
look at which layouts would be applied
on which device say your app is running
on a nexus 5 the Nexus 5 has dimensions
360 DP by 640 DP of the to the smallest
width is 360 DP so we use this number to
compare against the folder names 360 DP
is less than 600 and it's less than 720
so all the layouts will come from the
space layout folder for the Nexus 7 2012
version the dimensions are 600 DP by 960
DP of the two sides 600 DP is a smaller
width so we compare this against the
folder names it turns out that the
smallest width is greater than or equal
to 600 DP so for the detail and item
layouts we pull it from this folder now
the main XML file is not declared in
this folder so we fall back to a less
specific folder which turns out to be
this one in the base layout folder for
the Nexus 10 the dimensions are 800 DP
by 1280 DP of the two sides 800 DP is
the smallest width now this device
satisfies the categories for all of
these because 800 is greater than 720
and greater than 600 however the system
chooses the most specific folder first
so it will choose this item layout over
these two since the detail layout is not
defined here it will fall back to a less
specific folder which is this one then
for the main dot XML file it's not
declared in either of these so it falls
back to this one